okay thank you very much uh welcome to
uh the Corto session and I have the
distinct pleasure of talking about
things that look like a St a stack of
Crepes but actually they're manuscripts
so today I'm going to be talking about
reproducible manuscripts with Corto so I
want to talk uh a little bit about the
full sort of spectrum of um complexity
of reproducible scientific prod projects
what do I mean by that um majority of my
time as an educator particularly and an
educator who tends to teach students who
are learning Computing for the first
time and does so with Corto I live in
this wonderful land it is a fantastic
place to be you have a single Corto
document you are sort of like coding in
one language because that's the language
we're teaching the students and we have
full control over sort of like
everything that they're doing including
the tools that they're using to write
their code and the type of things that
they're producing
while you know quite in depth for them
are things that where the code can all
live in a single file and they don't
mind running it over and over again with
each edit you want to change a header
fine let's just run the whole compute
again and things go pretty fast and
pretty neatly and we tend to get HTML
outputs as a result and we can publish
them on the web um while that's like a
majority of the time I'm living in
breathing the rest of the time I am
thinking about well we collect data from
these students about how they learn at
some point we're going to want to
publish these results so how do we go
from the simplest case to things that
get sort of progressively more complex
so from simplest to let's go to simple
um we can again have a document a single
quto document with just some R code in
it and with the help of the Corto
Journal articles extension I can output
things to PDF or word and not just
output to any PDF or word but a document
that looks exactly like the document the
journals I'm submitting my uh
manuscripts to um expect them to look
like but again the code in here is sort
of um I'm going to say simple enough
that's not to say the analyses are very
simplistic but to say that I'm okay
rendering this document every time I'm
making edits to that and this is a happy
place to be too but science is rarely
that simple um generally you're working
with multiple collaborators each with
their favorite Computing language and
code editor and you're in multiple
stages of a project each with their own
level of feasibil of what can be rerun
with each edit and what needs to be
cached you don't want to be cleaning
your data every time you want to change
your headers for example so a more
complex project might look like this
maybe you have a single uh quto document
but a bunch of notebooks and stuff
laying around and maybe everyone's
coding in r in your team and you want to
Output to something like a PDF or word
for a journal submission or things can
get even more exciting where you have uh
sort of the diversity of the tooling
your uh collaboration team is using
increases where we have even more
notebooks where little bits of the
project are being done maybe we have now
multiple qmd files some of them running
our code in them and some of them
running python code in them but
ultimately we need to bring all of this
together into a culminating manuscript
that we want to submit to a
journal um we can turns out leverage the
notion of quto projects for um writing
these fully reproducible scientific
manuscripts so I'm going to step take an
aside for a second and
uh talk about a little bit of a mind
shift uh for some of you and at least
for myself as well whenever I use the
word notebook in my mind I'm always
thinking about like Jupiter notebooks
because the word notebook is in there um
but ultimately a notebook is a document
that contains both code and narrative so
going forward when I say notebook I
could be talking about a Jupiter
notebook or I could be talking about a
quarter document where you again see
your code and narrative in the uh same
place so let's keep that in mind and
think about what the current state of
affairs is
most computational science is born in
notebooks and it dies that's sort of not
so nice maybe ends in PDF or Word
documents and what happens in between is
that we have peer review and publication
workflows that don't tend to support
these notebooks as research outputs and
these more complex scenarios that I
talked about involve a lot of like
manual finagling at the end and not in a
devious way but you know just at the end
of the project you're just trying to get
it over the threshold
uh to bring the project to this journal
submission stage and it's during this
Pro uh process that oftentimes
reproducibility is lost um or at least
take some sort of second seat to
formatting requirements I will at least
be honest and say that I have certainly
done the thing where I had this
beautiful notebook that I got to 90% of
what the journal wanted as a word file
and then I manually edited that word
file and I just like and then I put a
footnote saying the code can be found in
the GitHub repository Choose Your Own
Adventure um and ultimately the final
submission that the journals want or
archive want rarely captures all these
computations I mean sure they'll happily
take your supplementary documents but
really rarely archive those documents
with your manuscript and sometimes
they're not necessarily even reachable
um so these can live in supplementary
materials sometimes and there is no
ensuring that that GitHub repo I L to
and my supplementary documentation is
going to be there a year or two years
from now so if you've tried to reproduce
others as work so that you could learn
from them and iterate on it you probably
have had difficulty trying to sort of uh
gather up all the pieces needed as
well um so there is um you know this is
the current state of affairs but also
within the current state of affairs
there's lots of great minds thinking
about well how do we make this better
this is not a new problem and there's
been sort of like initiatives various
initiatives over at least my academic
career of sort of trying to move
reproducible computational science
forward and one of the sort of the
current ongoing projects is this
notebooks now project um that's funded
through uh this uh Sloan Grant and uh
Grant from the uh American geophysical
Union and the idea is to try to sort of
um make these pieces work well so what
could a road map look like for full
reproducible scientific manuscripts that
are not just PDFs that are the outputs
of a single qmd file so what we need is
one piece of the puzzle is we actually
need an actual publishing workflow an
endtoend scholarly publishing workflow
starting with that first notebook you
started you know iterating on when you
had the idea for your project to the
final manuscript that you uh produced
that TR treats things like Jupiter and
co uh quto notebooks as the primary
element of scientif ific record not just
that PDF output we also need a
publication process that sort of
elevates transparent and reproducible
workflows by authors where they are able
to sort of bring together and submit um
and archive their software along with
their document and their data and this
is going to take obviously lots of doing
on the Publishers end but it is putting
on a bunch of uh new work good work good
scientific work but new work on the
authors as well so hopefully along with
these initiatives come sort of new forms
of credit to the folks who are working
on this as well um I'm going to focus on
the first two pieces of the puzzle where
Corto can provide Technical Solutions to
that and maybe perhaps then provide
bandwidth for others to work on the
third piece of the puzzle as well so
with Corto it can be authored in your
favorite code editor so you no longer
need to you know convince your
collaborators to change their home um
you can render qmd files or Jupiter
notebooks to a variety of outputs you
can execute code in R Python and more
you can apply Journal style uh to your
outputs with these Corto extensions and
publish to you know a variety of venues
including GitHub pages netlify and more
now last year I said all of these things
at at this conference and over the Year
I hope that many of you have tried these
uh things and with Corto projects we
know that we can sort of orchestrate
this notion of multiple inputs and
multiple outputs well um now with a new
project type that's the manuscript
project type uh you can orchestrate
these multiple inputs and outputs again
but you can also leverage this idea of
embedded computations that I'll talk to
you about in a little bit so let's
introduce this new project type um this
is Cordo 1.4 onward so there are pre-
release versions available right now on
the Cordo website but it is not
available yet on the uh release version
we can produce manuscripts in multiple
formats and give readers an easy way to
sort of peruse them by creating a
website that goes along with it and we
can publish the computations so that
readers can both sort of take a look at
the computations and even go a step
forward hopefully and start interacting
with the computations as well so let's
go ahead and write a manuscript you can
start you know any of these CTO projects
in one of two ways you can say well
create an empty project for me are
either using the r Studio IDE is usually
what I tend to do um or you can use the
command line interface and do something
like CTO create project manuscript my
favorite paper for example or go to the
Corto documentation and grab one of the
uh projects that we've already sort of
like prepared for you so that you can
see all of the pieces working together
and start replacing the bits of the
narrative that don't relate to your work
uh with your data and your narrative and
if you do this in a uh uh in a folder
that is being tracked by git and has a
GitHub repository associated with it you
can have pretty easy goinging with your
publishing as well so with um one
command like Cordo publish you end up
with a website that looks like this uh
for your uh manuscript so what we're
seeing here is a variety of things that
you would expect from a manuscript we
have figures that are um actually um
cross referenced and if if I hover over
these I can sort of see the cross
reference figures as well um I can see
that the Articles the notebooks where
the computation is happening is sort of
linked on the side and one of my
favorite things that's sort of like on
by default is you can you know go ahead
and uh start doing things like
highlighting the text oh come on um and
also you know if you have you can set up
a group with your collaborators and say
something like hey maybe we want to you
know phrase these things slightly
differently so this hypothesis feature
is turned on and so you no longer have
to just like be doing those PDF
annotations you can start interacting
with things in this
way um another thing is that from this
one single Source you get multiple
formats so on this rendered web page you
can see that we're referencing to a PDF
that has the um agu format so has the
journal format as well as a word file so
starting with the same yaml of my
project right I have one yaml that says
I want a HTML I want a PDF I also want a
word
file um I can actually get to this
output where I'm able to see um an
access each of these formats in addition
I get really rich front matter so you're
probably used to you know yamal that are
a few lines long this is like a whole
novel in and of itself this yaml but the
need for this is that um some journals
want some things and other journals want
other things and it's nice to be able to
sort of put everything on there maybe
you each time you start a project you
have a standard AML that you fill with
your collaborators and if you're
submitting to um this journal then only
the relevant pieces will be picked up
and rendered there and for the word
output that we were able to access from
that homepage again only the relevant
pieces get picked up and fit in there as
well for the next bit I'm going to sort
of uh show you a video of how we can
actually um not go sort of break this
Paradigm of a single quto file but also
uh grab computations from and uh
notebooks as well so I have a CTO file
um and the data set that goes with it as
well and let's take a look at the
contents of that CTO file I'm housing
all of that in the same folder as my
manuscript and if I go ahead and render
it you'll see that this particular
notebook is not like my paper it's just
a few things I was trying maybe one
table or a one figure I have created and
let's assume for a second that there was
a lot of compute required to create one
of these then I go to my main document
my manuscript and I uh start using an
embed short code to say I'm not going to
bring in that code chunk here what I
want to do is I want that code chunk to
stay in my notebook um but I'm going to
EMB it in my main manuscript so I'm able
to grab the label of that um code chunk
and Link it
here and let's go ahead and take a look
to see that uh the table that we
produced in our um notebook is embedded
with a link that can take me back into
the notebook as well I had some rcode in
this document my main manuscript was at
qmd and I embedded at qmd here as well
and this is also a nice opportunity to
show you uh some of the um sort of nice
uh features of the visual editor in our
studio I'm able to sort of uh create
these cross uh references um sort of
pretty um in a pretty straightforward
Manner and gra um basically include them
in my
paper now let's imagine that while I am
the person who likes to write code in R
I have a collabor Ator who has created
this fantastic visualization in their
Jupiter notebook using python code so
I've now received their notebook where
they had already executed the code and
what I can do here is again I can now
embed in this same qmd file output from
that notebook as well so I'm able to
bring in outputs from different
languages and different types of
notebooks into the one manuscript file
and uh and not having to render that
code again or reexecute that code again
but simply grab the results that were
already created when my collaborator
made that visualization for me and I can
again using the same syntax um using the
same syntax uh do a cross reference to
that as well so let's go ahead and
convince ourselves that that actually
works if I scroll down I have my lovely
visualization made with python and let's
pop that
out
I can go to the qmd file and start
interacting with that notebook or I can
go to the IPython notebook and start
interacting with that as well from the
single
document so what is next after this um
well what what I demonstrated here is
that you can start perusing the code
which is fantastic um and at times
that's perhaps all you need in fact when
I I um was sort of like first starting
to play with the manuscripts feature I
was thinking I wish it would just sort
of you know pop out and let me take a
look at it and then go back to its home
I sort of want to convince myself as to
how that figure was created but maybe
I'm going to focus on reading this paper
uh for the remainder of the time but
when it comes time to actually perhaps
taking somebody else's paper and saying
I really want to understand how they
implemented this method or how they
created this table I might want to to
genuinely dive into the Cod and sure I
could go to the supplementary
information and go to their GitHub repo
and clone that repo and start get
started but we know that there are a lot
of hurdles along the way when you do
that so I want to interact with that
code in a computational environment
that's just a click away that has all
the software and packages needed to
reproduce the manuscript in 2019 there
was this article published in nature
that where actually an article on eif
allowed you to do this um as of today
that article is paywalled and you can't
access the links anymore so this is and
this is not to say the authors did
anything WR it's to say it's been years
and this is a very sort of like near and
dear to a lot of scientist Hearts
problems that's really diff difficult to
solve so I think with the manuscript
feature with Corto we're like making
advances into getting there so as of
today you can start kicking the tires on
the CTO use binder feature where you can
see in addition to sort of these stat
outputs you have a link to uh to be able
to launch a binder binder instance you
do need to be a little bit patient as it
does its thing there but we would love
for you to sort of go in and take a look
to see how this is working for you is it
capturing everything that you need um
and is it working out for you and give
us some feedback on that as well so
where do you go from here I would
recommend rewind back to that get
started and start again and I would uh
point you to the document ation for the
quarter pre-release where uh Charlotte
has actually created a wonderful
repository that you can get started with
thank you so much for listening and I'd
be happy to take
[Applause]
questions ah I'm back thank you for the
great presentation thank you so um I'm
going to turn things real real quick
with one question when we submit a
manuscript we often don't do it just
once um do you have any tips for a
workflow like if you have to switch
templates because you're submitting to a
different journal and or resources
slways to contribute to the pool of um
Journal templates that are already
available yeah wonderful so um it's
actually that first bit is easier than
you think and I know that we don't tend
to write an article for multiple
journals at the same time it generally
tends to be iterative where you maybe
submit to one and then you try another
but you can add other templates here as
well so in this case I only had on line
10 here one of the journal templates
being used but you can add other ones
here as well so I could have added
something like posos PDF or jasa PDF and
kept going and um CTO will happily
render all of them for you grab the
necessary bits of the ammo and create
those PDFs for you um there is a rich
and growing sort of ecosystem of these
extensions and I think the best way to
contribute if you have a journal you
want to submit to is grab one of the
ones there's actually a starter repo in
that quarter journals um uh templates
organization as well and you know start
sort of like playing around with it um
you may or may not if you need a PDF
output you probably want to be sort of a
little bit confident with writing a bit
of like lat latex styling code but I
would also say that if you've started
with a template for a journal of
interest to you um but you're running
into roadblocks opening some issues and
asking for help would be great as well
as the developers are often like
watching that space and trying to help
people get over that
hurdle awesome thank you very
[Applause]
much